[Music]
good morning John it's Tuesday June 19th
I'm back in the basement again I'm
the basement again I'm mostly
underground and you can't hear a sound
cuz I'm back in the basement again it's
pretty comfortable down here I uh made a
little nest for myself where I can level
up and come down here when it's too hot
outside and then back in the basement
again
but I don't envy you having to move out
of your house having to leave your
little studio I wonder what's gonna be
in the background of all your new videos
this is still gonna be your bookcase or
are you gonna do it somewhere else
maybe really Hood 2.0 viewers would like
a change of setting every once in a
while I mean for a while people were you
know impressed by my map of the realm of
Narnia and my floating bookshelves back
there but now nobody talks about that
anymore
maybe I should start filming upstairs in
my bedroom with the cat at the Missoula
skate park maybe some more from downtown
Missoula or from Target you know on
location not today though but I'd be
interested if people have suggestions so
what's the news you asked oh let me tell
you there's news there's this news you
might not be impressed with this kind of
stuff John anymore but I'm still very
exciting for me
I can go to Barnes Noble and be like hey
I wrote this that's me
people will gasp you're famous just like
that
famous and I'll say you don't know the
half of it
the other day I was wearing my
Brotherhood 2.0 in my pants shirt and
that lady came up and asked me about it
I thought that was actually kind of
brave of her I mean would you go up to
somebody who had a t-shirt like that I
mean I've seen a lot of weird t-shirts
in my time but I don't generally walk up
to people ask them what they're about
there's an idea for a project asking
people about their t-shirts gotta find
someplace public with lots of t-shirts
and be like what the it's the future he
saw it and it's going to cross him a lot
of times there's no explaining I mean
talking to strangers is fun right as
long as the t-shirt doesn't say
something like don't talk to me about
t-shirt or I will put forks in you that
would be an amazing t-shirt other news I
was on the Weather Channel I mean I knew
that they had recorded me for The
Weather Channel but then suddenly I was
actually on the Weather Channel I missed
it but it will be on again several times
the show is called forecast earth
I believe the particular episode is
entitled something about hotness heat
global heat heating up heater or heaters
space heater space heater probably not
it starts out I think with John Kerry
and I'm the very end for that's
definitely my first national television
appearance and I'm pretty sure that they
mentioned Brotherhood 2.0 Wow Wow anyhow
I talked to the Yeti this afternoon and
she and John were in the moving truck
leaving New York actually trying to get
out of the city while in a moving truck
which I'm sure can't be very easy so let
us all get together and say lucky lucky
lucky lucky lega lega woo good luck
getting out of the city and getting to
Indianapolis good luck moving into your
new house good luck doing a video
tomorrow while moving into your new
house cuz that's gonna suck and thanks
for your video it always sucks leaving a
good place I hope I don't have to do it
anytime soon I'll see you tomorrow I
hope